l'invité de sao qu'a dit ce matin nadine
renard vous êtes la présidente de la
commission agriculture de la ctm bonjour
nadine renard
première demain et pendant deux jours
vont se dérouler les assises de
l'agriculture organisé par un septième
la chambre d'agriculture quels sont les
objectifs alors en fait c'est ainsi ils
ont été voulus par le président de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
également par le président de la chambre
d'agriculture
parce qu'en fait depuis de nombreuses
années les acteurs du monde agricole
n'avait pas encore eu l'occasion de se
retrouver pour échanger discuter depuis
2009 alors voilà la dernière rencontre
avait lieu en 2009 lors des états
généraux de l'alimentation suite à la
grève de 2009 et puis il y avait eu des
assises il ya une trentaine d'années à
peu près mais depuis il n'y avait pas eu
de nouvel événement de ce type qui
permettent de regrouper l'ensemble des
acteurs pour partager du partage
d'expériences échanger sur diverses
problématiques et puis s'accorder sur un
certain nombre d'orientations
commune et puis définir également des
priorités pour l'action dans le monde
agricole pour avec un objectif d'aller
vers une agriculture pour pour demain
qu'il soit une agriculture durable alors
d'accord on va on va y revenir justement
sur l'agriculture de demain mais déjà
vous avez est-ce que vous avez déjà
cerné les problèmes les difficultés de
l'agriculture martiniquaise alors les
difficultés sont d'ordre divers et
d'ailleurs lors de ces assises nous
allons aborder à travers diverses
thématiques mais voilà il ya cette
thématique par exemple l'image l'image
qu'ils renvoient
revenu le foncier la production la
politique agricole la coopération
l'environnement et la santé tout ça ce
sont des thématiques que nous allons
aborder et faire le point sur les
problématiques liées à ces différentes
thématiques justement ce qui est quelque
chose de plus important pour selon vous
à aborder toutes la même bien ya
plusieurs axes importants il ya si on
prend par exemple la problématique du
foncier il ya l'accessibilité au foncier
aujourd'hui qui est parfois difficile
pour les jeunes agriculteurs ja la dispo
de la mise à disposition de terre on a
beaucoup de terres en friche marc
anthony qui sont soit en indivision ou
pour d'autres raisons mais que la
martinique dix jours jusqu'à 7000
hectares par an c'est ça ça représente
ça il ya toujours cette perte latente en
termes de foncier et il ya cette
problématique de la perte du foncier à
au profit de l'habitat qu'il faut
aujourd'hui préserver justement et c'est
sur ces aspects là qu'on va échanger sur
la préservation du foncier il ya divers
outils qui existent pour pouvoir
permettre de lutter contre ça et puis je
m'engage et il faut loger les gens mais
fait aussi de l'agriculture voilà sur
une île qui n'est pas extensible voilà
il faut trouver le bon compromis et est
valorisé notamment un certain nombre de
terres en friche qui aujourd'hui ne sont
pas exploitées donc il ya des procédures
qui existent et qui qui ont déjà
commencé à être mises en oeuvre qu'il
faut aujourd'hui renforcée amplifier un
jeune agriculteur puisqu'on parle du
fond si on va parler que tu te dis
jeunes agriculteurs ja l'agriculture qui
aujourd'hui je se lancer dans le métier
est-ce qu'on n'y pas eu tous piste ce
qui n'est pas fou ce qui n'est pas non
pas du tout je crois que l'agriculture
martiniquaise a encore de l'avenir et
aujourd'hui il faut il faut encourager
les jeunes justement à travers un
certain nombre de dispositifs à mettre
en place encourager les jeunes faciliter
l'installation et les accompagner
également à travers le processus
d'installation
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que l'agriculture
on va pas se mentir ce n'est pas un
métier facile à la base c'est déjà un
métier qui est difficile qui est soumis
à de nombreux aléas notamment des aléas
climatiques et pour un jeune agriculteur
qui s'installe il ya un certain nombre
de contraintes il ya également il faut
le dire la concurrence d'un certain
nombre de produits agricoles qui
viennent de l'extérieur qui sont à très
bas coût très bas coûts et qui se nouent
les six de faire de les acheter des
produits locaux parfois s'aggrave le
prof pourtant sa grève peut-être le
porte monnaie mais il faut se poser la
question de la qualité aussi parce que
quand on achète des produits qui
viennent de l'extérieur dont on n'a
aucune idée de la traçabilité parfois ce
sont des produits qui ne sont pas
produits dans les mêmes conditions et
avec les mêmes exigences réglementaires
qu'on peut avoir en martinique et la
qualité de ces produits n'est pas du
tout la même que les produits locaux
qu'on peut trouver donc c'est aussi il
ya aussi un travail à faire sur la
valorisation de la production locale
pour que le consommateur soit
suffisamment informés et un travail
aussi bien sûr des prix alors le travail
sur les prix il est il et je dirais
qu'il peut être aussi par
l'accompagnement qu'on peut proposer aux
agriculteurs pour leur permettre
d'investir enfin leur permettre d'avoir
accès à un certain nombre d'outils et
d'équipements qui leur permettent de
sortir des coûts de production
abordable on va dire pour le
consommateur menti mais la
qualité aura de toute façon un coût plus
important que quand vous avez du poulet
qui arrivent d'europe
et qui du rop de l'est et qu'il y ait un
ou deux euros le kilo vous aurez beau
faire vous ne pourrez pas être
concurrentiel par rapport à ce produit
là mais très sincèrement la qualité n'a
absolument rien à voir est ce que le
consommateur martiniquais recherche
d'abord la qualité parce que quand une
famille monoparentale
avec toutes les difficultés que cela
comporte veut nourrira les deux enfants
on va pas parler de famille nombreuse
lorsque c'est un peu cliché mais ouvrir
deux enfants est-ce qu'on se tourne
obligatoirement vert
la qualité ou bien on réfléchit à son
budget alors c'est vrai que de manière
générale aujourd'hui on ne consomme plus
comme il y a vingt ou trente ans et
c'est vrai que la part qui est laissée à
la
l'alimentation dans le budget se réduit
de plus en plus donc une famille va être
amené à faire à faire des choix quelle
image aujourd'hui à l'agriculture
martinique est qu avec l image
on nous professionnels alors nous allons
aborder d'ailleurs cette question lors
des assises puisque nous avons mené une
enquête auprès du du grand public que
nous allons instituer lors de ces
assises cette enquête a été d'ailleurs
très intéressant puisque bon je ne vais
pas dévoiler mais l'image de
l'agriculteur et de l'agriculture
martiniquaise est une image qui
aujourd'hui est une image satisfaisante
et pour laquelle il ya encore à faire
certes pour valoriser cette image pour
promouvoir cette image non seulement à
travers le monde agricole mais également
je pense à travers le tourisme notamment
puisqu'il ya il ya tout un potentiel à
exploiter pour amener les touristes à
découvrir notre patrimoine aussi bien
notre patrimoine
culturel mais également notre patrimoine
en terme de deux produits du terroir en
termes de savoir faire en termes de de
même du point de vue de l'art ou
transformation et un certain nombre de
produits qui existent et qu'il faudra
valoriser au niveau haut niveau tout en
fait l'objectif que c'est aussi de
sortir de l'image que l'on a de
d'agriculture liêu ce qu'on a connu la
chlordécone des blés aux pesticides pour
ceux un peu améliorer cette image
et proposer une agriculture plus saine
également oui alors cette image
s'améliore parce que je pense que les
consommateurs suit effectivement aux
différents à la problématique de la
chlordécone et et ou aux problèmes
sanitaires qui est qui qui en découlent
il ya un certain nombre d'efforts qui
ont été mis en place et un certain
nombre de contrôles également qu'ils
sont mis en place et qui qui aujourd'hui
amène les consommateurs à être je pense
un petit peu plus rassuré par rapport à
ou en tout cas à savoir qu'il y à des
contrôles qui a quand même une
traçabilité etc aujourd'hui
l'agriculteur est également engagée dans
une démarche beaucoup plus vertueuse par
rapport à l'environnement et par rapport
à la santé lundi challenge c'est aussi
de trouver l'équilibré entre une culture
d'exportation et une diversification qui
pourrait permettre une autosuffisance
alimentaire c'est aussi ça le challenge
alors l'autosuffisance alimentaire
complète j'ai tout lu je crois je ne
pense pas que ça soit forcément réaliste
et réalisable maintenant je crois tout à
fait qu'il est un pas entendre d'axer
les efforts sur un développement et un
accompagnement de la diversification
parce que il ya une demande il ya un
besoin on a aujourd'hui besoin de
trouver un certain nombre de produits
qui sont
deux produits de consommation courante
qui soient des produits qui viennent de
martinique on ne veut dire je sais pas
je pense à la tomate par exemple je
pense à avaya des produits qui qui qui
doivent être des produits de notre
terroir et qui doivent venir et donc à
ce titre là il est important d'accès nos
efforts sur la diversification pour
préserver l'agriculture martiniquaise
est ce qu'il faut taxer davantage
l'importation alors ça pourrait être
un axe effectivement je voudrais quand
même revenir sur la question de la
diversification des cultures
d'exportation je pense qu'il ne faut pas
opposer les deux et que les deux sont
nécessaires à notre économie donc aussi
bien les cultures d'exportation qui ont
vocation à
exister et à contribuer au développement
économique de la martinique et les
cultures de diversifier une
complémentarité en fait entre les deux
qui font qu'il faut maintenir alors
l'agriculture de demain il nous reste
que 30 secondes l'agriculture de demain
passe par quoi alors l'agriculture de
demain à mon sens ce doit être une
agriculture durable durable au sens du
développement durable c'est à dire
durable du point de vue social
développer la vision davantage mettre
l'homme au coeur de
l'agriculture donc et puis au sens de
l'environnement donc oui les
agricultures vertueuse tout ce qui va
dans le sens d'une agriculture raisonnée
biologique développer les pratiques
agroécologiques etc et puis également du
point de vue économique être qu'une
agriculture qui permettent aux
agriculteurs de pouvoir vivre
correctement de leur médecin nadine
renard merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation passé une excellente journée
à l'écouté de nos programmes merci à
vous bonne journée
[Musique]
l'état